all that into account when you talk
about the chemistry of the team you just
mentioned 6 through 10 including one
through five have to be ready to
sacrifice with this roster that you have
and the guys that you're in the locker
room with does it seem like everybody is
willing to sacrifice and if so what does
that do for the chemistry of the team
this year compared to previous years I
should say um I think
uh I I can't name one person um in there
that hasn't shown the willingness to
sacrifice thus far and and I don't see
that changing that doesn't mean a guy
isn't going to be mad that he come out
the game we're competitors we want to
play um but when it was all said and
done I got my teammates back uh I'm not
going to be a distraction to this team
and I think you know that's great last
year we had an awful team as far as
chemistry goes um it was pathetic uh but
chemistry has been a strong suit here
that's why Steph has been here for 15
years clay has been here for 13 I've
been here for 12 and Lun has been here
for nine cuz chemistry is a strong suit
in Andre odal the list goes on and on
that's why so many guys have been around
here for so long because the chemistry
is what we've hung our hat on well you
look at last year you say oh man this
team hasn't lost a uh a western
conference series under Steve Kerr and
then it
happens a big reason why is our
chemistry sucked and so you know I don't
look at that as oh man like this is a
team that you know we we we've struggled
with chemistry I mean yeah we struggle
with our chemistry
for years it was a onee thing things you
know stuff happens and it was an anomaly
but you know we're right back where we
need to be in in that department and
most importantly I think there's still
room and will be growth in that
department I was refering to last year I
just want to be oh yeah no it's all good
um last year was
horse it's hard to come to work y'all
see me trying to do Clay's little paper
airplane uh it was hard it was hard to
come to work um not fun you know uh and
so this year you see the joy uh you know
on guys's face when they come in the
building you got guys like staying over
two and three hours after just sitting
around talking getting here two and
three hours early just to be here you
know it's like you start to see that and
you're like okay this is a group that
likes being together but like we did
some stuff this summer and had dinners
together and no one was running out the
door you know it's usually that guy
that's like oh man when can I get out
and yet you're looking around trying to
see like somebody and no one's trying to
get out and I think you know we're we're
trying to build on that and that'll be a
big key to our
season I mean this is Clay's type of
thing like how childish is this right of
course this is
Clay anybody think it's going to fly
y'all doubt all right y'all not all
right so about four people doubt not
doubting
me a